[Music]
i
am going to be discussing today my new
book the corona crash
which comes out on the 27th of october
and it really builds on the themes
of uh my previous books stolen how to
save the world from financialization
which i presented
um not so long ago it must be about six
months ago at uh how the light gets in
earlier this year
um but that rook book really looked at
the kind of pre-existing problems that
our economy was facing even before the
pandemic hit
so stolen was really the story of the
rise and fall of finance-led growth
which i described as this
um particular kind of political economic
regime
that governed our economy uh the
government the uk's economy the us's
economy broadly speaking the global
economy to a greater or lesser extent in
different places
um really kind of from the 1980s onwards
and it was characterized by um you know
what a lot of people refer to as kind of
neoliberal ideology when it comes to
governance
so regulation cutting taxes uh financial
deregulation in particular
uh privatization a general retreat of
the state from
providing a lot of the kind of uh
services that we previously relied upon
the state to provide um that uh
gross model i argue and stolen um was
premised upon
a couple of different elements that made
it pretty unstable
so financialization um which was the
kind of process at the core of finance
led growth
drove a lot of different changes in the
way our economy works and in the book i
look at how
uh the firm the household and the state
all became
financialized and i also talked a little
bit about how the global economy
became for more uh financialized and
really what that means
is that um kind of financial
institutions so
banks hedge funds pension funds etc um
and
financial kind of motives and operations
more generally so that's really the kind
of logic of
lending and investment become much more
prominent in
uh basically all areas of the economy so
you had the financialization of the
corporation
which was associated with the kind of
dominance of the ideology of shareholder
value
which basically meant that corporations
came to focus pretty much solely on
their their share prices
um rather than you know what we might
have
previously thought of as a kind of
stakeholder model of corporate
governance or even you know rather than
actually
um doing what many of these corporations
were built to do which was kind of make
things and
provide services there was a kind of
singular focus on this on this idea of
maximizing shareholder value and the
ways in which that was pursued so
particularly um excessive dividends
payments
um increasing kind of mergers and
acquisitions activity
share buybacks for example uh
general reorganization of power that
took place within the firm so
workers wages were much were lowered
relative to the wages
and perks that were gained by senior
executives
and obviously the ratio of pay between
the average worker and ceos
increases substantially over that period
um and that
really created a lot of the problems
that we see with corporations today so
there are those kind of problems of
governance the fact that
um stakeholders the fact that workers
the environment aren't really big
factors in a lot of corporations
decision making but also some like
more kind of structural economic factors
so the fact that we've seen a kind of
long-term decline in investment
uh in fixed capital amongst corporations
so you know
a corporation was less likely to say
build a new factory which would have
created
jobs or you know invest in research and
development and it would be to kind of
basically play around with its share
price so that has created all sorts of
problems around productivity
and at the same time obviously we had
this internal redistribution of power
which led to
a falling wage growth and has led to i
mean then this has happened
across the kind of rich world a fall in
the wage share of national income a rise
in the profit share of national income
that brings us on to how it affected the
household so you had a massive rise
in um in borrowing um and a lot of that
was mortgage borrowing because obviously
at the same time as these changes were
coming in
um you had a big housing boom you had
the deregulation of commercial banking
which made it much easier people to get
mortgages and to get debt more generally
and you obviously also had right to buy
so a lot of people were kind of buying
um using this newly created credit to
buy housing
and that as we know was explained in the
book drives this uh this bubble that we
see in the housing market in the uk and
then eventually
the us which ultimately obviously brings
the whole system
crashing down and then you have the
financialization of the state
which was associated with um the kind of
incursion
of private financial institutions into
the operation of
uh the management of public services the
provision of
infrastructure you can see this with the
the private financing initiatives but
also
with outsourcing more generally which is
of course very much coming back to bite
during this pandemic when outsourcing
companies are basically being charged
with running the government's corona
iris response
and not doing so very successfully at
all
um so yeah and it's also associated with
actually the rise of this idea of
asset-based welfare which is that rather
than
um kind of socializing risk throughout
society risk is increasingly
individualized so
people are encouraged to have private
pensions to store up
savings in their home and that's really
what's going to be what's going to
protect you from any negative shocks in
your life rather than
the state itself so these are all
factors that are associated with
financialization
and kind of as i argue in the book and
as i write at the beginning of this book
those processes severely weakened both
the uk economy and the global economy
and the run-up to the pandemic
obviously we have the financial crisis
which kind of brings the
energy the dynamism that exists within
that model to a halt a lot of the
productivity gains that we saw
pre-financial crisis were driven by kind
of financial innovation which is
just a euphemism for finding a more
ingenious way just to uh extract money
um from uh i mean ultimately it was it
was mortgage
holders but also various other areas of
the economy um
so that obviously you know came came
crashing down um but you also had these
secular problems within corporations
where we had
an underlying trend away from kind of
investment in
making things and kind of providing uh
services um that were innovative and
investing in research and development
and those sorts of things and towards
much more speculative activities at
least amongst many corporations in the
global north
as well as because of these trends
towards uh
well i mean obviously increasing
shareholder value the best way to do
that
really is to kind of corner a particular
market and gain a monopoly position so
that was another way that firms have
done that and
we saw a steady increase in monopoly
power over that period
and ultimately those are the trends that
ultimately gave rise to
that period that we've had since the
financial crisis which was characterized
above all by massive stagnation so there
were those kind of
underlying trends that were making the
economy less dynamic
but also you know there was this huge
buildup of debt before the financial
crisis
and then after the financial crisis that
debt had to be repaid and that was
basically you know the growth we had
before the financial crisis
was uh at the expense of future growth
because that's really what that is if
you're not using debt for investment
then you are simply taking your future
earnings or your future income
and having it now and that's really a
bit another big reason why we saw a lack
of dynamism in the
economy since 2008 because obviously
we've had a decade of
wage stagnation a decade of productivity
stagnation
poverty and inequality um increasing in
some areas of the economy inequality
absolutely increasing we now
know that we've been systematically
understating the extent of inequality in
the economy because of the capacity of
many individuals to hide
income uh as you know uh wealth
basically
income from work as income from other
sources or to hide income
as actual uh physical wealth which has
prevented us from accurately
understanding the scale of inequality in
this country but some researchers have
actually just done some research that
shows that it has grown quite
substantially
so you know we had uh low productivity
low levels of investment
big current account deficit because uh
we have basically been relying on
financial flows into our
financial sects into our into the city
of london really predominantly
rather than you know creating exports or
renovating and they
allowed us to compete internationally
and obviously that's all kind of
overlain with this
long deep secular crisis of climate
breakdown
and that was the kind of economy that we
had in the period just before the
financial crisis so it was one that
wasn't particularly productive that was
highly unequal
and in which a lot of both individuals
and corporations
were massively overburdened by debt and
this is an interesting theme that we'll
pick up on later this theme of corporate
debt because if the 2008 financial
crisis was largely a crisis of kind of
um personal debt of mortgage debt and
the way in which that was kind of uh
transformed into this
very valuable asset by the financial
system then a big part of the crisis
we're facing now has to do with
corporate debt it has to do with the
debt of kind of ordinary corporations
um because obviously at least partly
because of the low interest rate
environment
you know the combination of very low
interest rates but also
not a very dynamic economy so businesses
could borrow money very very cheaply
but they didn't really have much of an
incentive to invest it productively
because there would be no guarantee that
there will be demand for those products
down the line so
it kind of exacerbated that problem of
stagnation because you're borrowing lots
of money but often you're not using it
for investment you're simply borrowing
money
because it's very cheap and maybe you
can use that to buy property or to buy
back your own shares
and indeed we saw from the big tech
companies especially
then because they're so able to borrow
money so cheaply
they were actually borrowing money from
uh from banks from
investors and using that to buy up
higher yielding bonds
in other companies so they were
effectively acting like banks using
their capacity to borrow very very
cheaply
to gain control of other areas of the
economy and that's the interesting thing
about debt
is that it really is a power relation so
you know for the average person debt is
a kind of
um it's a chain around your leg whereas
for a really big powerful corporation or
for a big investor
that is what allows you to actually
expand your ownership and therefore your
power
over the rest of the economy to continue
watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you